you
students in India look at Nobel
laureates as a sign of great success how
much of mentorship you think that is
very important in you know making people
really passionate about science all that
has to be a mentoring the challenges
because you have to grow intellectually
you have to grow in your capacity to
generate ideas and see ideas through to
some sort of reasonable conclusion I
would say that as a scientist the
characteristic of scientists that they
keep it's very motivating for us
anxieties to have an interaction with
Nobel laureate helps us to grow as a
scientist just as a student of science
and also as a human being for somebody
was deciding as to what kind of science
they want to do the area of research
would you recommend passion and what you
like or would you also insist on some
amount of practically or almost any
subject when you get into it becomes
totally fascinating and so the important
thing is to have a good mentor a good
lab where you're in a good environment
with people you like and get on with and
you can talk with and learn the basic
skills you need for doing science he
made everybody feel very comfortable to
talk was open for all the questions it's
useful for young people to know that if
you do science and you do complex
science you kind of get it wrong some of
the time
not getting it wrong you're just doing
boring experiments basically the whole
idea is that the students are you know
are exposed to first-hand experience
dealing with the Nobel laureate and also
in an area which many of them are
interested in who want to pursue
immunology as a carrier they see that if
you choose this path there's so much you
can achieve and contribute to the
society to give back in many ways I
think it's very inspiring I like the
fact that even as a Nobel laureate and
the fact that he's he's been everywhere
and he's learned so much he's so down to
earth and he still has that passion for
science I was very encouraged by the
fact that there's such bright young kids
and it's so enthusiastic about what
they're doing and things are really
moving here and it's very impressive
what more can one ask about the best
person the best immunologists you can
think of and here's a great opportunity
for them participant this lecture this
morning was is Gretchen on so what the
taste of does is because it focuses on a
modification of the transplantation
value that's what it will discovered
that the teaser was specific in some
sense for self major histocompatibility
complex the way in which he looked at
the science that was available at the
time when he did his work that was work
done in 1973-75 at the John Curtin
skilled medical research in Canberra two
of us in a lab with a technician quite
young completely independent which was
fantastic I did the mouse experiments
thinking I oblivion EHR experiments I
read the papers if I'd done in vitro
experiments and inconel original papers
you would never heard about working with
academicians brings out fresh ideas and
kind of inspires us to come out with
simpler solutions to problems I think we
could learn quite a few lessons from
prof sorority's approach to science very
instructive to turn the labs and hear
how things actually work and what you're
dealing with
it's done and actually see some real
chemistry being done out there enough in
the hood I'm learning more from you than
you're learning from me to our group
thanks to the a so seneca nobel medicine
initiative we have had the opportunity
to hear professor dougherty to engage
with him in a really challenging
question and answer being able to
interact with individuals who achieve
great heights and science which are
being recognized by the nobel prize only
inspires you further to do more in the
field of science